the fight back has already begun yes
about about an hour ago
um the uh the department for health
issued a statement saying that he's
gonna
come out fighting tomorrow just on
today's hearing and we we were expecting
a four hour hearing
turned out to be seven hours and seven
minutes um
he kept calm he was great stamina
obviously kept calm
didn't get rattled with any of the mps
we were expecting criticism of the prime
minister and yes we got it
but it really was the attack on mr
hancock
that was brutal really it was a
demolition job
the allegations of lying of incompetence
and everything else
but within minutes of the committee
ending we got this statement from the
department of health
and a spokesperson has said this at all
times throughout this pandemic the
secretary of state
uh for health and social care and
everyone in the department
has worked incredibly hard
to uh incredibly hard and unprecedented
circumstances to protect the nhs and
save lives
we absolutely reject mr cummings
claims about the health secretary the
health secretary will continue to work
closely with the prime minister
to deliver the vaccine rollout tackle
the risks posed by variants
and support the nhs and social care
sector
to recover from this pandemic now
tomorrow
the health secretary will come out
fighting twice
first of all in the house of commons
because he's going to answer an urgent
question
from labour's jonathan ashworth earlier
in the week he didn't turn up he sent
nadeem zahawi
the vaccines minister we he will turn up
tomorrow
and we are assured later he will host a
government news conference
one of the number 10 news conferences in
downing street that'll probably be at
five o'clock
so uh whereas the prime minister at
pmq's today
chose to ignore mr cummings barely
mentioned him turned his fire on sakiya
starma
mr uh uh mr hancock is going to fight
back tomorrow
john you've been watching these things
for many years perhaps let's say
decades have you ever seen anything like
it
well i can remember i first started
covering uh parliament in 1982 the year
of the falklands war
and i remember there were some very long
select committee hearings then
for example some of the journalists who
went to the falklands gave evidence
mps gave evidence officials and minister
of defense and others gave evidence
i cannot recall a hearing of seven hours
and seven minutes
nothing like this i mean there was no
there were hot there were only some very
short breaks too
i mean sometimes if you're going to have
a very long hearing you might have a
lunch break or something like that
there was just a short break for prime
minister's questions
um and as i say mr cummings who
by all accounts can be a combustible uh
combative individual
at times all the anecdotes one hears
about him from inside whitehall
and yet um he used the odd bit of bad
language as did one mp who got ticked
off by the committee chairman greg
clark but he stayed calm
i would have thought mr cummings would
be pretty pleased with his day's work
because he's made all the points he's
wanted to make he kept
again and again and again attacking matt
hancock so he clearly had him in his
sights
uh he did also and criticized the prime
minister's competence
uh he made a few uh uh comments about
what he called the prime minister's
girlfriend
didn't call carrie simons the pm's
fiance
talked about her complaining going
completely crackers
uh he said about a story about the
couple's dog
that appeared when they were trying to
deal with covid and also
the power struggle late last year when
she tried to get some of her
friends appointed so plenty of targets
well once it got off lightly rishi soon
never got criticized really
um uh despite his strong views of posing
lockdowns
the pm came in for some criticism but my
word
the most savage brutal criticism was
directed at matt hancock
who now is planning his fight back